Il y a une nouvelle émission
qui vient de sortir
ça s'appelle Top Chef,
j'sais pas si vous avez vu.
10 septembre 2010
Cyprien marche tranquillement dans la rue.
Au même moment un astéroïde menace de
s'écraser sur la terre.
Aucune mesure n'est prise par
les forces dirigeantes
qui n'ont pas été prévenu à cause
d'une erreur d’inattention.
Heureusement elle se dégrade dans l'air,
pour ne devenir qu'une poussière
qui entre en contact avec
un cheveu gras de Cyprien,
et par une réaction moléculaire
qu'on peut pas vous expliquer maintenant
associée à une facilitée scénaristique,
une faille spatio-temporelle est créée
qui propulse Cyprien plusieurs année en avant,
et ça, il n'en saura jamais rien.
Je suis atteint de la malédiction Top Chef.
C'est à dire que le soir de la semaine où
je mange le plus de la merde,
c'est le soir où y a Top Chef.
On mange quoi ce soir ?
Bah j'ai pris tous les restes de la semaine,
je les ai mis dans un Tupperware,
j'ai mis un petit peu d'eau, au micro-ondes,
ça fait une sorte de quiche, voila,
et pour le pain on a des croutes de pizza.
30 secondes !
Ils le font exprès ! Ils le savent !
C'est pour nous dégouter de mal manger.
Laissez-moi manger de la merde tranquille.
Y a un truc qui est fourbe avec Top Chef,
dès le début, c'est le générique du début,
avec la tête de tous les candidats,
ils devraient enlever le visage des candidats
éliminés au fil des semaines,
ça parait évident !
Désoler mais c'est pas bon, pour vous
l'aventure s'arrête ici.
Du coup c'est possible de m'enlever du générique ?
Oula pas du tout pas du tout !
On va montrer votre visage chaque semaine
à des millions de téléspectateurs
qui se diront "putain mais j'ai aucuns
souvenirs de ce type".
Niquel.
C'est ça Top Chef.
Franchement les mecs qui font l'émission, wow hein,
franchement bravo, parce-que c'est
super bien rythmé déjà,
la musique ! Vous avez entendu la musique
qu'ils mettent dans Top Chef quand même ?
Ah, tu regardes Pirates des Caraïbes ?
Non, je regarde un mec qui coupe
des poireaux !
Et il se passe quoi cette année ?
Ils ont changés presque tout le jury bordel !
Thierry Marx, y a plus Thierry Marx,
mon préféré !
Bon voila il est parti pour des nouveaux projets,
pour des trucs gastronomiques, culinaires,
super pointus à mon avis,
qui lui prennent beaucoup de temps,
c'est surement ça.
Lustucru "Comme un chef",
les pâtes qui donnent envie de les cuisiner,
comme un chef.
Et le seul membre du jury qui reste,
c'est le robot là.
Ah bah attendez, n'essayez pas de
me faire croire
que Jean-François Piège est un humain.
Quelqu'un qui se tient naturellement comme ça,
est forcement une intelligence artificielle.
Excellente cuisson, c'est un coup de cœur.
Et qui ils ont pris dans le jury, qui ?
Philippe Etchebest !
Le mec qui te hurle dessus non-stop comme ça :
Confiance en toi bordel ! Elle est où ta créativité.
Fais sortir ta créativité !
Si tu te reprends pas elle va partir celle-là ok ?
Les mecs perdent tous leurs moyens parce qu'il hurle,
donc ils font de la merde, donc il hurle.
En même temps c'est normal de perdre ses moyens,
face à quelqu'un qui n'a pas de sourcils.
C'est déstabilisant.
Mais tu nous fais quoi là ?
Merde ! Ils sont où ses sourcils ?
Il les avait au début de l'émission ?
C'est contagieux ?
Je veux pas perdre mes sourcils moi !
On va pas se mentir hein, tous les ans c'est
un peu la même chose,
tous les ans y a les mêmes épreuves,
tous les ans ils doivent cuisiner pour des gamins,
tous les ans y a un fayot qui décide de leur préparer
des légumes à la con
pour impressionner le jury.
alors pour les gamins je leur ai fait du navet hein.
Avec du choux mariné.
Une petite farandole de légumes oubliés,
avec une petite sauce aigre-douce,
tout-ça ça fait une forme de poisson,
les gamins ils adorent les formes de poisson.
Ah c'est dégueulasse ! Ah je veux mourir !
Je veux mourir !
Ah bon ?
Maman c'est vraiment pas bon !
Ah je m'y attendais pas à ça...
tous les ans, c'est celui qui prépare des pâtes
qui gagne cette épreuve.
Ça fait 6 ans maintenant.
L'épreuve de la boîte noire.
Ça c'est un truc de ouf.
Ils doivent reproduire un plat,
qu'ils doivent goûter, toucher,
dans le noir complet. Dans une boîte géante.
Avec des caméras infra-rouges.
C'est un peu chelou en fait.
Alors, j'ai bien tout gouté, hein,
j'ai tout mis dans ma bouche,
je pense qu'il doit y avoir des fruits de mer,
et peut-être du fromage,
un fromage un peu fort, hein.
Qu'est ce que c'est, pourtant j'ai bien
léché partout.
Ça va me revenir.
Le moment horrible dans l'émission,
c'est la finale.
La finale c'est super gênant,
les finalistes doivent préparer des dizaines de menus,
aidés par des mecs qui ont été éliminés avant.
Les mecs on leur a dit désolé, l'aventure s'arrête là,
t'es vraiment trop nul va-t'en !
Attends reviens, tu vas aider quelqu'un d'autre
à gagner.
Alors vous avez devant vous des gnocchis de patate douce,
émulsion de chorizo, et une sauce au fois-gras
préparé par heu... par heu j'ai oublié son prénom là,
le mec qui s'est fait dégager la première semaine, voila.
Bonne dégustation !
alors pour savoir quel candidat a gagné l'émission,
parce qu'il y a quand même de l'argent à la clé
tout ça,
ils font une petite mise en scène, ils vont chez
les finalistes,
avec tous leurs amis, toute leur famille tout ça,
et ils doivent tirer un couteau,
si la lame est orange, ils ont perdu.
Alors, j'ai peut-être l'esprit tordu mais,
moi de base, instinct de survie,
si j'annonce à quelqu'un qu'il a perdu,
je lui met pas une arme blanche dans les mains.
Allez vas-y !
Ah bah lame orange c'est perdu,
les 100 000 euros vont aller
à l'autre candidat,
c'est vrai que l'anti-gel dans les gnocchis
ça a pas convaincu, c'était pas une très bonne idée.
Faut faire attention à l'assaisonnement, ça manquait
de sel parfois, c'est vrai que...
Et la lame rouge ! Ça veut dire quoi la lame rouge hein ?
Ah, ça manque de sel.
Il faut faire attention, à l'assaisonnement.
C'est important.
Alors Top Chef ça a pas changé ma vie, hein,
je mange toujours pareil malheureusement,
à si, y a une petite différence.
Avant je me faisais à manger comme ça,
et maintenant comme ça.
Je mange toujours de la merde,
mais c'est stylé.
Abonnez-vous
Sous-titré et Synchronisé
par Kuistoh
Sous-titres réalisés para la communauté d’Amara.org